the largest climate protest since the
start of the pandemic is taking place
around the world today with more than
1500 demonstrations in over 80 countries
they are organized by fridays for future
the youth-led movement calling for
urgent action to avert catastrophic
climate change
hundreds of rallies are happening in
germany alone
demonstrators are ramping up pressure on
the candidates competing to replace
angela merkel at this sunday's elections
a few minutes ago climate activist greta
tunberg addressed the crowd in front of
the bundestag let's listen
the climate crisis is an accumulative
crisis the co2 we emit now will be up in
the atmosphere for up to a millennia
it is just as much about our present and
future missions as it is about our
historic emissions and that's why we
need to have historic emissions in mind
when we ensure climate justice
and while we're at it
germany is the fourth biggest emitter of
co2 in history
for a nation of about 80 million people
that's quite an achievement germany is
objectively one of the biggest climate
villains
but we are not only stealing the future
from our children and grandchildren we
are also stealing the present from the
most affected people in the most
affected areas
those who are already suffering the
consequences of the early stages of the
climate and ecological crisis and those
who have contributed to this crisis the
least
and now as we move out of the pandemic
many are talking about using this as an
opportunity for a green sustainable
recovery whatever that means
and world leaders are talking about
building back better
promising green investments and setting
vague and distant climate targets in
order to say that they are taking
climate action
however the fact that we are in a crisis
that we cannot build buy or invest our
way out of seems to create some kind of
collective mental short circuit among
the people in power
and the longer they pretend that we can
solve the climate crisis within today's
system
the more invaluable time we will lose
but even if we ignore that fact
when you look at we are actually
investing the money in the money that's
supposed to be building back better
it shows the hypocrisy of our leaders
it turns out that the green recovery
they are talking about isn't so green
after all
only two percent of government's
recovery spending has been allocated to
clean energy according to iea
and 2021 is currently projected to
experience the second highest emission
rise ever
and according to a new report by the un
the global emissions are expected to
rise by 16 percent by 2030 compared to
2010 levels
yes you heard that right
time and time again the people in power
show their true interests and priorities
and it is not an overstatement to say
that they simply don't seem to give a
damn about us
we can no longer leave this to the
people in power to take care of
and let's get more on that statement
from greta tunberg she's speaking just
moments ago in front of the german
bundestag dw's anja koch at the
demonstration anya an incredibly strong
message timber going directly after the
halls of power tell us a little bit more
about what she had to say
i unfortunately have a very very hard
time understanding you you might be able
to see and hear there's a lot of music
and speeches going on but i'm going to
try to answer your question anyway as
far as i understood it greta juneberg
was just speaking a few minutes ago the
young swedish
woman who once inspired this movement
and
she said that during those past 18
months we have all seen how vulnerable
we are referring of course to the
coronavirus pandemic and she said that
you know during those last 18 months it
was very hard for fridays for future
movement
to go demonstrate demonstrations
especially as big as this one didn't
happen during those last 18 months
she also said she called of course
on the german government saying that the
german government is not doing enough
to cut those emissions and she said that
for a wealthy and and big country like
germany this is not something that's
acceptable and she said that the people
are demanding change and that she hopes
that when there are enough people taking
to the streets that this change is
coming
anya tell us because as we've heard
there's more than 1500 demonstrations
happening all around the world today for
this cause and it's interesting to see
toonberg actually coming to germany
we know that the german federal election
is on sunday how much could this protest
impact the vote
well i talked to one of the organizers
of this demonstration of this
demonstration earlier and she said
that this does not have anything to do
with the german elections
she said that the date for this
demonstration and the strike worldwide
uh that it was set a long time ago and
that
you know it's a worldwide strike so it's
not it's not supposed to be a message to
german voters but of course it's hard to
believe that i mean this demonstration
has taken place right in front of the
german parliament and it's hard to
believe that this is not meant to be a
signal to those maybe still undecided
voters
that go to that have to cast their
ballot on sunday
and your german buddhist talk thank you
anya
cities like berlin and london are
regularly seeing tens of thousands of
people rally for action on climate
change
in poland the climate strike movement
struggled to get off the ground
one high school student took it upon
herself to change that
over the last two years she helped grow
the polish fridays for future into an
organization that has caught the
attention of people in power
they hope to bring some change to what
may be the biggest challenge in human
history
maya martina and emilia are climate
activists
this friday they are skipping school
again and taking to the streets to make
their voices heard
for maya the crisis means much more than
global warming and rising sea levels
it's a very human crisis
and yeah i just want to make the
connection that
we're all connected nature
humans
yeah the climate crisis and
social crisis she fears for events such
as extreme weather and the economic
fallout the crisis will have on
vulnerable communities around the world
maya's journey started here in her
hometown toron the city of astronomer
nicolas copernicus under the scientist's
watchful eye she joined her first march
calling on politicians to listen to
science and act
i saw the banners all the slogans i just
got so excited and just felt
such a connection to the people and the
fact that
people really have the power to change
things
um so yeah the strike just gave me a
knowledge like an overview of how
how really people can make change and
how i can contribute to this
since then she has organized multiple
events herself
but here in her native poland not
everyone supports her cause
the country's energy runs largely on
coal and the government is planning to
keep it that way for many years to come
this summer maya filed a lawsuit against
what she calls the polish government's
failure to act we have to remember that
the more the polish government
procrastinates uh with the
transformation because of the economic
situation the transformation and the
rising costs of emissions
the situation of the polish economy will
also
be in harsh situations whereas the
climate movement still isn't mainstream
here like for example in neighboring
germany
slowly it is becoming more recognized
and despite the pandemic limiting
in-person activism the polish community
continued to organize online reminding
people that another crisis was in full
swing
a crisis should be treated as a crisis
and we've seen that
for instance the media have
at least
in poland
have grasped the
emergency of the pandemic
and
we didn't see anything like this when it
comes to the climate crisis and we knew
about the climate crisis much earlier
maya osbaolo says a lot is at stake and
that she and her peers are determined to
take their future into their own hands